we're not a NASCAR fans ready for action
and that includes our very own eight
Sports now Logan Reaver he's been
cooking up stuff up in the Johnny Walker
RV at the Las Vegas Motor Speedway Lots
going on welcome back to Logan's Pit
Stop did you leave the truck Logan
I I finally left the truck they say you
have to get away from home at some point
they got to let the bird fly free I have
finally done that for a whopping half a
mile all the way down here to Pit Road
where I'm joined by Jeff Motley the VP
of PR for the speedway you've obviously
done this for a number of years does it
ever feel any different the same feeling
resonate I'm enjoying the fact that it's
a little cooler weather right now that's
always different this in October and
it's a lot better and I think our fans
are loving it too just based on how many
people are going to be out here this
weekend and all the rvers that are
already here yeah what have you what do
you sort of gather from that obviously
you know you get the the Mainstays the
new people that come along with it is
there ever you know when you're kind of
looking around it's just sort of the
pageantry that comes along with this
event do you has it ever kind of
resonate in a new way yeah I think it
absolutely does you know this is going
to be the latest we've ever had this
race we're farther into the playoffs so
there's a lot more at stake and from a
racing standpoint there's only eight
drivers left that are in the playoff
hunt right now so if you're one of those
guys and you win this week you're
automatically in the final four race to
the championship race so I think there's
a lot of excitement there on both series
that's going on but like I said the new
cooler weather and stuff is just getting
more people out because who doesn't want
to come to Vegas in October this is true
and and really quick I got about 20
seconds here but the amount of Vegas
guys that are involved in this weekend
in this race just how cool is that
that's unbelievable you got Kyle Busch
and Noah Gregson on Sunday and Noah
Riley herps Matt Jasco all running on
Saturday we got a bunch run over at the
bull ring tonight you can keep rattling
them off until it just goes numb in the
face that is the case Jeff Molly
appreciate the time in the meantime
we'll send it back to you guys
all right Logan thank you very much
there an exciting weekend at the
speedway and